descendants fans are curious to find out
if Celia fassl the air will be as wicked
as her father's reputation sure she
might have the evil cackle down past but
it's possible that she'll have a change
of heart by the end of descendants three
watch until the end to find out the
truth about Celia and whether or not
she's going to be a threat to Oregon on
May 10th
2019 Disney descendants released a
trailer titled is it uma which showcased
uma side of the story
although Celia is not mentioned
throughout the short teaser we do catch
a glimpse of her at the very end of the
video the tarot card that flashes across
the screen has Celia's name on it and we
are seeing her holding the key that
frees Hades in her left hand as she
raises her right hand up high so it was
only a matter of time before Celia's
very own trailer was released we don't
know much about Celia so far however we
do know that she's a daddy's girl who
puts other villains maniacal laughs to
shame so Before we jump into the reasons
why Celia might not be the villain she
appears to be let's get some background
info on her character and find out what
she's made of many of us didn't know
that dr. Faso leer had more than one
daughter
however Disney descendants has confirmed
that Celia is in fact the youngest
daughter of dr. facile ear
Celia's oldest sister Freddie has made
appearances in the animated short series
descendants two wicked world and returns
the Isle of the Lost a descendents novel
she's described as a slick talker who
can convince people to do anything she
practices voodoo magic and can cast
spells but despite being a wicked and
conniving character Freddy isn't exactly
evil sure she might use her powers for
her own good but she isn't rotten to the
core like her father is it takes Freddy
a lot of time to shed her villainous
ways but she eventually does okay so we
get in find that jewel and get out
before anyone sees us now many
descendants fans are wondering if Freddy
will make an appearance in d3 but if she
doesn't does that mean Celia is going to
be taking over Freddy's role if this is
the case we might see Celia have a
change of heart before the end of the
film although some of us think that
Celia will be taking over Freddy's role
some fans believe that uma is
actually Freddie in disguise this is
because actress china anne mcclain
voiced Freddie's character in the first
season of descendants wicked world
however she gave her spot up when she
was cast as uma and her younger sister
Lauren McClain took over the role Kuma's
father B dr. Vasily R is she half
sisters with Celia we're excited to find
out the truth come descendants 3 but
first let's find out everything there is
to know about the evil voodoo doctor
Freddie and Celia called dad dr. Faso
Lear isn't someone you want to mess with
in fact he's one of the things that go
bump in the night like the other
seasoned villains on the Isle of the
Lost
dr. Bashir was brought back to life and
imprisoned by fairy godmother dr. Vasily
are used to live in New Orleans where he
worked as a witch doctor who made
backhanded deals with unsuspecting
victims vasily ER is a man with little
honor and many friends on the other side
he is a wordsmith who knows just what to
say and to get what he wants he enjoys
watching his clients squirm when his
Dill's go awry oh and all he's just not
that great of a guy fassl ear is the
villain from the Disney movie The
Princess and the Frog it's here that we
find out that he plans on murdering
Prince Naveen and Big Daddy Lyubov all
fascinator wants is a big piece of the
labo fortune so that he can become the
most powerful man in New Orleans
unfortunately for him the newly dubbed
Frog Prince finds true love and breaks
the spell he's under and by the end of
the film
dr. fossil ears betrayed by his minions
and loses everything but that was the
old dr. facile ear the new and improved
witch doctor has learned from his
mistakes and plans to teach the younger
generation everything he knows Fassel
ear is the founder and headmaster of
dragon hall which is the school that the
kids on the Isle of the Lost all attends
dr. Vasily R is an intelligent and
highly persuasive person who always has
a hidden agenda so we can expect great
things from him in descendants three and
by great we mean terrible while it's
true that he has a way with words the
villain also has a set of supernatural
powers many of which he has passed down
to his daughters Freddy and Celia's
father is a bokor which is a voodoo
witch for higher
is left-handed voodoo magic which is
considered to be evil the sorcerer is
extremely powerful and can use his dark
voodoo magic to accomplish pretty much
anything when he looks at someone he
sees more than just their face he sees
what they desire most in the world and
let's just say he uses it to his
advantage dr. Vasily r uses his tarot
cards to do his evil bidding but there's
something about these cards that make
them stand out the cards changed their
faces to adhere to facile ears victims
wishes the cards tend to show the
victims future in a positive way however
there's usually a clue on the card that
reveals what fassl ears real plans are
in the Princess and the Frog dr. Vasily
r told Prince Naveen
that he would have freedom and green but
freedom takes green making him believe
that he'd be rich when in reality the
green represents as his life as a frog a
lily pad could be seen on facile ears
tarot card however Naveen chose to see
what he wanted to see and got duped in
the process all in all facile ear has an
array of magical powers most of which he
owes to his friends on the other side
and it appears as though Freddy and
Celia also have these magical voodoo
powers however whether or not their
shadows move on their own accord is
still up in the air all right so so far
we know that Celia's father has a lot of
influence on the Isle he teaches the
youth everything they need to know about
villainy so we can only expect
Celia to be one of the most despicable
vks on the island kids want to make
their parents proud which is what caused
Evie now Jay and Carlos to try to take
over our Don in the first place so we're
not surprised to see Celia reaping her
father's colors and style from head to
toe if we didn't know any better we
think that Evie designed Celia's outfit
herself it looks totally wicked during
an interview with pop sugar actors Jada
Marie revealed that Celia literally
copies her dad's style from the top of
her hat to the bottom of her feet
according to Jada a costume designer
Khorasan paid tribute to Disney's
original witch doctor when designing
Celia's outfit much like her dad Celia
even sports a little voodoo doll and
skull hat
but just because Celia chooses to dress
like her father doesn't mean that she's
a carbon copy of him after all Maui
J and Carlos all looked like their
parents too before they chose to be good
in fact most of them continued to
support their parents colors despite
having cut all contact with them but
that wasn't all Jada had to say about
Celia Jada Marie had a chance to talk
about her character during the Disney
Channel fan fest the young actress
revealed that being cast as Celia was a
dream come true and that descendants 3
was going to be downright amazing when
asked about her character
Jada explained that Celia is very much a
daddy's girl she also confirms that
Celia is mischievous and all about the
cash like her father she went on to say
that Celia looks up to her dad so at
first we were led to believe that Celia
would make her daddy proud and help
bring down the barrier however Jada also
mentioned that Celia looks up to now
which is quite strange since most of the
aisle hates her but just when we were
going to accept that Celia might be a
good VK Jada explained that no matter
what
dr. facile ear is Celia's rock and
people don't just betray the most
important person in their lives if Celia
does in fact look up to Mao it's going
to be hard for her to portray her idol
this is especially true considering that
Celia will have a chance to get to know
the vks on a more personal basis it
looks like Celia might have a very tough
choice to make on April 5th 2019 Disney
descendants released the mystery trailer
and it took fans by surprise
this short jet jam-packed trailer
reveals a lot about Celia's character
and despite popular belief it paints
Celia in a bad light we first catch a
glimpse of Celia standing next to Evie
while uma transforms into a sake' Leah
although it may seem like Celia is
fighting alongside the good guys she
could be manipulating the situation we
also see a board looking Celia unlocking
the door to Haiti's lair shortly after
we hear who we believe to be Celia
saying that a great evil will have the
revenge and all in auradon will pay
forever a few seconds later we see
Knights and armor putting up their
swords against mal and her friends while
Celia holds do the dog in the background
did she use magic to SiC the knights on
the V case because from where we're
standing it looks like they're
protecting her top that all off with
Celia's evil laughter and
tarot card dance and we'd say we have a
classic villain on our hands however the
fact that celia is protecting dude the
dog is something to take into account
after all this wouldn't be dudes first
time helping a villain learn how to love
just ask Carlos deville man nothing was
nasty descendants three synopsis states
that a barrier breach occurs when Maui V
Carlos and J and Ben go to Arden Prep to
recruit the newest batch of e Ches
despite their best efforts the breach
results in a dark force threatening the
people of auradon since we later see
cilia walking the halls of our don prep
it's safe to assume that she alongside
dizzy and others were chosen to attend
to the school if this is the case then
dr. casselli are most definitely tasked
his daughter with a mission of some
sorts but the very same thing can be
said about each and every VK that gets
chosen to leave the Isle and since pain
suffering and evil is all the decays no
it's only normal for them to want to
make their parents proud
at first never forgetting one Thursday
hate king however after spending enough
time away from their not so lovable
parents Feeney BK's will choose to be
good like mal and her friends did in
descendants so despite being daddy's
little girl there is a chance that Celia
falls in love with Arden and chooses to
preserve its glory
however it's obvious that things need to
change in auradon
you can't just lump everyone you don't
trust on to one small island and
sentence them to live the rest of their
lives in exile that's just not right do
you think that dizzy and Celia will
become best friends they are about the
same age after all if they do we're sure
Disney's enthusiasm and love for life
might help sway Celia's evil tendencies
many descendants fans believe that Celia
will start out as the bad guy only to
show her true colors when push comes to
shove in fact it's a popular belief that
Celia Ouma Harry Gill and possibly Hades
will all turn a new leaf by the end of
descendants three we also might get to
see the decays squeaky and squirmy
leaves the aisle to attend our dime prep
alongside Celia and dizzy however
whether these two end up being good or
bad is up for discussion so do you guys
think that Celia is going to choose to
be
good or will she side with her father
and try to break down the barrier and
destroy our Don once and for all
Celia's allegiance can go one or two
ways but we wouldn't put it past her to
pretend to be good to get close to the
BK his own to end up backstabbing them
for now Celia's true colors remain in
the dark
so is Celia good or evil you be the
judge let us know what your verdict is
in the comment section below for more
videos about your favorite Disney
characters and movies subscribe to the
things and give this video a big thumbs
up if you love descendants thanks for
watching we'll see you soon
[Music]